[Applaus]
[Musik]
stellt euch land mit der bevölkerung ins
vor das jedoch über höhere öl- und
gasvorkommen verfügt ein land und gäbe
von den reichsten öl monarchie in
welchem land spreche ich gerade genau
von bahrain so künz land das es mit
bloßem auge kaum auf einer weltkarte zu
sehen ist ja ich weiß was du lässt dich
das leben dort ist traumhaft sein oder
geld für alle eine florierende
wirtschaft und stetes wachstum money von
abba magic software das genau gegenteil
ist
[Musik]
allein auf schrottstatus herabgestuft
als der politische verfall ungebremst
weitergeht
ja du hast richtig gehört war ein
schulden gelten auf dem internationalen
markt als schottland sogenannte junk
bonds das bedeutet dass der investoren
bezüglich der wirtschaftsaussichten war
heinz derart skeptisch sind dass wir
nicht daran glauben das land könne diese
kredite jemals zurück zeigt tatsächlich
sich die lage in bahrain wirklich
äußerst düster aus
falls er diese politik schon länger
verfolgt wisst ihr bereits dass es in
der islamischen welt zwei große
fraktionen gibt die sich gegenseitig
hassen zu nicken und schicken
wie ihr wisst ist saudi arabien so etwas
wie das muslimische hollywood dazu
nehmen und die islamische republik iran
ist das gleiche nur für die schiitischen
muslime
deshalb befinden sich beide seiten seit
jahrzehnten in einem kalten krieg
[Musik]
und inmitten dieses kalten kriegs
befindet sich bereits in der vertrackten
situation von allen grundsätzlich ist in
diesem land die bevölkerungsmehrheit
schiitisch aber das regierende
königshaus ist sunnitisch deshalb
erklärte die heimischen monaten
politische unterdrückung zu einer
eigenen kunstform
okay das ist bislang nichts was dich
sonderlich überraschen könnte aber hey
der titel dieses videos lautet doch
warum das bereist im land der welt
werden könnte oder so ähnlich also warum
sprechen wir hier nur über probleme aus
diesem grund war ein entdeckt das größte
ölfeld des landes seit 1932 ja meine
lieben zuschauer bereit verfügte bereits
über etwas - aber jetzt haben sie noch
viel mehr davon im grunde genommen
könnte bahrain über mehr öl verfügt als
russland und nur mit einem bruchteil von
dessen bevölkerung das heißt alles in
allem müsste man das ganze geld nur mit
recht wenigen leuten teilen
[Musik]
aber die frage lautet nun ist das genug
geld um zum wohlhabendsten land der welt
zu werden warum werden die
schuldverschreibungen bei heinz selbst
bei so viel öl immer noch als chance
betrachtet was ist denn los
heute werden alle diese fragen
beantworten aber bevor wir das tun
lasst uns einen blick in die geschichte
werden
ein goldener käfig falls einer von euch
eines tages decarta werden möchte hier
ein paar tipps grundsätzlich gibt es
zwei möglichkeiten menschen dazu zu
drängen die zufolge der erste ist der
offensichtliche die gute alte und das
problem
hindrichs mit der unterdrückung
übertreibst riskierst du einen
volksaufstand
mehr haben weil wir so albig 1000 immer
alle gesagt das ist riskant ist eine
karte zu sein also macht das lieber
nicht daheim nicht viele von diesen
leuten sterben nämlich ein alter
schwächer aber es gibt alternativen
gesündere und nachhaltigen weg die
strategie geld fürs nichtstun
im grunde genommen lasst ihr alle eure
bürger im geld schwimmen wie viele
kleine dagobert ducks
wenn die leute reich sind und keinen job
suchen müssen werden sie sich schon
schön aus der politik heraushalten so
weil die rechte die familie alter lief
war die herrscherfamilie in bahrain hat
diese beiden methoden hatte
unterdrückung und geld fürs nichtstun
sehr effektiv kombiniert tatsächlich hat
der premierminister dazu vielleicht der
onkel des königs ist den rekord als
längste als inhaber der welt er ist seit
1971 ununterbrochen an der macht
[Musik]
dennoch die kann eine sunnitische
herrscherfamilie in einem land mit
schiitischen mehrheitsbevölkerung so
lange an der macht bleiben nur die über
rad sagten auf der einen seite haben wir
die gute alte eiserne faust proteste
gegen die regierung gut dann wirst du
automatisch als der rest eingestuft sie
stecken dich ins gefängnis verurteilt
sich zu tode oder schicken nicht einfach
ins exil und entsprechen die nicht von
einzelfällen
das ist etwas was woche für woche
passiert
highland zieht 115 personen die
staatsangehörigkeit wegen terrorismus
vorwürfen über 700 menschen wurde in
bahrain sei 2012 die staatsbürgerschaft
entzogen
[Musik]
über 700 menschen in bahrain wurde seit
2012 die staatsbürgerschaft entzogen
ich weiß was du jetzt sagen wirst schon
marx sei nicht so ein den südlichen in
anderen demokratischen ländern würden
sie dir auch seine staatsbürgerschaft
aberkennen und natürlich hast du recht
aber der unterschied liegt in den
proportionen in großbritannien zum
beispiel gibt es einige solcher fälle
sicher man kann sie sich aber an zwei
händen abzählen in bahrain geht es um
hunderte und ok jetzt wenn es eventuell
dass sich die dinge zum besseren wenden
werden
die zeit schreitet voran einer osten
modell nun in diesem fall ist ist leider
genau umgekehrt im jahr 2011 während des
arabischen frühlings denen die
schiitischen bürger auf die straße und
forderten mehr demokratie
saudi arabien schickte zusammen mit den
vereinten arabischen emiraten truppen in
der bahrainischen regierung zu helfen
diese demonstrationen zu unterdrücken so
ist heute jeder 500 einwohner bereits
ein politischer häftling und unter ihnen
befinden sich natürlich viele schieben
führen und nicht oder seit 2011 hat
bahrain neuer gesetze verabschiedet die
es einfacher machen die
staatsbürgerschaft aufzugeben und glaube
mir der verlust der koranischen
staatsbürgerschaft stellt eine grosse
schande da der verlust der
staatsbürgerschaft bedeutet dass du alle
deine rechte verlierst
du musst einen pass und führerschein
abgeben
da ist kein haus kein auto kein telefon
oder bankkonto besitzen und noch nicht
mal rein
[Musik]
wenn du dich entscheidest auszureisen
dass du nie mehr zurückkommen und falls
du dich zufällig doch dazu entschließt
zu bleiben darfst du nicht mehr
ausreisen lässt sich sagen dass jegliche
opposition zur regierung dich zu einem
bürger zweiter klasse macht und das ist
verdammt schade denn ein erstklassiger
bürger bereits zu solchen liebe
zuschauer ist einfach verdammt moser
denn jetzt und die politik des gelds für
nichtstun und spielen das ist er sozial
vertrag dann bereit wenn man sich aus
der politik heraushält muss man sich um
nichts mehr sorgen machen müsste auf der
suche nach antworten
du bekommst einfach einen beim start und
keine sorge niemand werden die
kontrollieren und du überhaupt ins büro
gest falls du mal im supermarkt was
einkaufen musst wirst du aus dem staunen
nicht mehr herauskommen denn alles ist
hochgradig subventionieren einmal
volltanken
gut dass es fast umsonst okay du siehst
aus wenn du für ein privates unternehmen
arbeiten möchtest kein problem
die regierung garantiert quoten für
einheimische also wird er kein
einwanderer jemals seinen job weg gehen
und das ist eigentlich der lustigste
teil die quotenregelung vereinbarende
rhein im grunde genommen geht es darum
die coolsten jobs für die einheimischen
flüssig
[Applaus]
so müssen beispielsweise 50 prozent der
mitarbeiter einer bank aus bacher
einkommen in den coolen hippen
geschäften sind es noch 30 prozent ja
und bei bauarbeitern und nur fünf
prozent warum nun der bild schon unter
der glühenden sonne war eis zu schlecken
darüber lassen wir so einen scheiß top
doch einfach den 1
aus diesem grund sind 55 prozent der
bevölkerung bereit und sind diejenigen
die tatsächlich die wirkliche arbeit
erledigen der fairness halber muss sich
hier doch etwas anmerken den nahen osten
ist es sehr sehr verbreitet dass ein
staat mehr einwanderer als einheimischer
hat so machen beispielsweise
ausländische staatsbürger 75 prozent der
bevölkerung tages aus aber rein ist in
gewisser weise ein pionier
sie sind eines der wenigen länder die
die sogenannte kafka verbieten
und darum geht es bei der katar hat nun
das ist eine art moderne sklaverei das
kv system verbindet zwingend
ausländische arbeitnehmer mit einem
staatsangehörigen der ehe würde sein
muss und dieser bürger kann entscheiden
ob dieser migrant sein arbeitsplatz
wechseln oder sogar überhaupt das land
verlassen da bei allen hat diese
unendliche praxis abgeschafft gut so
trotzdem stellt sich vielleicht der eine
oder andere von euch dann doch die frage
ob einem land in dem kaum ein
staatsbürger wirklich arbeitet
langfristig gedeihen kann
und die antwort ist natürlich nicht
[Musik]
[Applaus]
120 dollar leben ohne zu arbeiten ist
ein teurer luxus und bereitschaft es nur
aus einem einzigen grund über die runden
[Musik]
es macht mehr als 60 prozent ihrer
exporte und 75 prozent der
staatseinnahmen aus aber um alle ihre
kosten zu decken benötigt die regierung
von bahrain einen ölpreis von 120 dollar
pro barrel weniger als 120 dollar macht
bahrain einfach nicht genug gewinn um
über die runden und ihr fahrzeug
vielleicht sind 120 dollar
viel oder wenig nun schaue an seinen
historischen höhepunkt im juli 2008 lag
das öl bei 147 dollar pro barrel
und wie ihr wisst samt der ölpreis im
jahr 2017 im januar 2016 4 auf 0 26
dollar
und das erklärt dann solche nachricht
standard and poor's senkt sein rating
auf b + die also versuchte bachrain sein
dilemma aus niedrigen ölpreis und stars
die zu lösen nun mit immer mehr schulden
das ergebnis spricht für sich in nur
zwei jahren ist die staatsverschuldung
von 7% auf 70 prozent in die höhe
geschnellt obwohl die rohölpreise weiter
steigen scheint es ziemlich
unwahrscheinlich dass er in naher
zukunft unter 20 dollar pro barrel
erreichen werden bislang hat bahrain
bereits intention für fleischprodukte
abgeschafft aber das ist erst der anfang
eine gehörte bis ende 2018 die
mehrwertsteuer einführen so der
finanzminister
ja du hast richtig gehört in bahrain
gibt es keine einkommenssteuer und
bisher hatten sie noch nicht nur einmal
eine ungerechte besteuerung aber die
situation ist verzweifelt und sie müssen
neue steuern einzuführen die es vorher
dort einfach noch nicht gab aber was
kann das für bahrain bedeutet nun
erinnerst du dich wie diese autoritäre
herrschaft funktioniert die schiitische
bevölkerung akzeptiert die unterdrückung
der sonys im austausch gegen geld fürs
nichtstun
wenn also die wirtschaft den bach runter
geht geht auch diese politik den bach
runter und tatsächlich könnte nur ein
wunder die familie al khalifa noch
retten das wunder was kommt jetzt
[Musik]
das öl wunder bisher produziert waren
täglich 200.000 barrel
das ist nichts im vergleich zu den elf
millionen saudi arabiens wenn sie aber
die größe des landes berücksichtigen ist
das doch eine hohe menge bin ich mal als
sagte hat man gerade ein richtig fettes
ölvorkommen entdeckt und sie könnten in
weniger als fünf jahren mit den pumpen
ist die gesagt ist also
[Musik]
[Applaus]
daran sich der optimistischsten
analysten dürfen sie noch mit die
förderung verdoppeln und ihr
staatsdefizit außerdem gibt es also doch
ein problem als tollwut politics
zuschauer an die es bereits nicht jede
art von rohöl ist es gleich viel wert
[Musik]
und dieses neue ölfeld hat alle zutaten
die man braucht und einen sehr sehr
hohen preis auf den markt zu erzielen
aber zunächst einmal befindet es sich
tief unter dem meeresboden was bedeutet
dass bachrain teure ölbohrplattformen
bauen muss und zweitens handelt es sich
um öl das bedeutet dass es unter einem
felsen liegt man braucht fracking
technologie um diesen steiner zu
besprechen und diese fracking
technologie ist alles andere als billig
[Musik]
in dieser grafik seht ihr die
produktionskosten eines ölfass in
verschiedenen ländern
wir können nicht abschätzen wie viel das
fracking in bahrain kostenlose aber wir
können uns daran orientieren wie viel es
in den vereinigten staaten ausgeht wenn
ihr auf die tabelle schaut werdet ihr
sehen das schiefe öl deutlich teurer ist
als normales damit man überhaupt gewinn
erzielen kann sollte ein barrel über 60
dollar einbringen
aber da sie eine enorm hohe gewinnspanne
benötigen um alle ihre ausgaben zu
decken brauchen sie einen noch höheren
marktpreis was also kann bahrain vor dem
untergang bewahren nun die antwort ist
die gleiche wie in anderen ländern des
nahen ostens diversifizierung andere
dinge als und produzieren und das wird
auch versucht
um die leser eröffnet 90 millionen
dollar teure fabrik der zukunft in
bachrain wenn bahrain aber wirklich
firmen aus anderen branchen ins land
locken möchte braucht es etwas anderes
als ölfelder sie brauchen
rechtsstaatlichkeit eine klare
steuersystem und eine regierung die
menschen nicht ohne prozess ins
gefängnis wird dubai und allgemein die
vereinigten arabischen emirate haben
diesen weg bereits vor jahren
eingeschlagen auch saudi-arabien könnte
diesem beispiel folgen obwohl wir uns in
diesem fall alles andere als sicher und
es ist nur eine frage der zeit bis
bachrain ebenfalls diesen weg
beschreitet aber wenn diese
wirtschaftsform wirklich dazu führen
dass die bachrainer steuern zahlen oder
sogar wirklich arbeiten müssen
dann bekommt die herrscher familie ein
echtes problem
[Musik]
[Applaus]
die große frage lautet also glaubt ihr
dass die mehrheitlich schiitischen
bachrainer eine derart autoritäre
sunnitische regierung akzeptieren werden
wenn sie nicht mehr durch den money for
nothing politik bei der stange gehalten
werden glaubst du sie könnten einen weg
finden es systemen irgendwie zu
reformieren lasst uns im
kommentarbereich wissen wir die weitere
entwicklung einschätzen und vergesst
nicht dass wir jede woche drei neue
videos veröffentlichen also abonniert
diesen kanal klickt auf das gloggnitz
symbol damit er keinen beitrag verpasst
wenn dir dieses video gefallen hat gibt
uns ein like daumen und bis zum nächsten
mal
[Musik]
[Applaus]